being an algorithm engineer that's in
your in your blood that's in your you
know it's it's it's it's something about
about it and trying to solve health
problems right and and just you know
understanding them really well and then
finding a solution welcome to 20 minute
leaders just sit back relax and learn
from the leaders of today it's a journey
each one is different unique inspiring
let's get started
[Music]
20 minute leaders is a proud supporter
of Make-a-Wish Israel and Tech to peace
and is in proud collaboration with
secret Court Ventures J Ventures
Riverside Femme Fusion VC Birthright
Excel J impact leap Google for startups
and hippo and in media partnership with
ctek
Ronan Darr welcome to 20 minute leaders
thank you so much for being with me
today how are you good good good thanks
for having me good to be here
great to have you here on and you are a
co-founder and CTO of an incredible
company run Ai and I'm very uh very
excited to be here
um the last time I saw you you were
speaking to myself and to a group of
other
um faults from 8200 in in our group 8200
for startups which I think we were
hosted in your offices if I remember
correctly or with tell the partners or
some some constellation which was a very
which was very really cool because I got
into this world of AI and you as an
algorithms engineer together with the
Marie co-founded a really cool company
that's taking the AI Revolution to
another level and really harnessing a
lot of the beautiful aspects of what it
is and so I'm excited to dive into both
your world and that of run Ai and and
take it from there so again thank you
very very much for for being here
tell me a little bit about you as an
algorithms engineer where what is it
what is your relationship with
algorithms in general from a I guess an
engineering perspective
oh wow it's taking me long time ago uh
that's you know I started my career as
an algorithm engineer so you know a lot
A lot has happened since I was I was on
the Rhythm engineer but being an
algorithm engineer that's in your in
your blood
you know it's it's it's it's something
about about it and trying to solve
health problems right and and just you
know understanding them really well and
then finding a solution so I started my
career in I know at first it was first
in our Intel I was like a student in
Intel but first my first like full-time
uh job was was in animate anovit was uh
maybe you heard about uh in hanabit I
know it was amazing amazing startup
umstein was the CEO and founder of of
Anna which he came from Tel Aviv
University he was a professor for
electrical engineering in in Tel Aviv
he's an amazing person I I get to know
you really well so he started around
under a bit and and I was walking there
in the algorithm group so we built you
know sophisticated algorithms for with a
coding and an algorithm for for
getting bits out of storage systems and
just decoding them in an efficient way
in a smart way and and that you know
those days were really really fun I saw
like how you start a company how you
build it how you scale it and then the
company was was and then sold to a hotel
so it was atel's first acquisition here
in in Israel and we were I think 200
employees went after bought us
and now now there are I think more than
1 000 employees here in the enactus
development center yeah they involved
more startups here in Israel they hired
a lot of more more people and and really
they're doing amazing stuff in this
Development Center they're building
Hardware they're building software
solutions they are in the iPhones in the
Apple watches you know Max the other
thing it's it's really it's okay it was
a big big success and I started there I
sold a car which is how it is to be in
there in a in a startup scaling that
startup I remember those days that that
was that was fun for me as an algorithm
engineer
and so the transition from an algorithms
engineer to co-founding your own company
where where was that leap from an
entrepreneurial perspective for you
I mean listen I I I I did it I was an
algorithm engineer and and it wasn't a
move for manoby to to do a to a founder
of a startup and
during my time in Arabic I also I also
did my masters in Tel Aviv University
and afterwards I also did my PhD so in
parallel of me being in Arabic and I
needed like more more challenge academic
Challenge and so I went to the to the
Academia and I've been there for many
years and I didn't like PhD in
information Theory information theory is
you know it's it's a whole very complex
theory on on how to get information out
of data and
and and I did my PhD there so I was I
was I was doing both industry in
Academia and after
my PhD where I graduated I moved to the
states I did my postdoc actually so I've
been in New Jersey I did my post
document in bed labs in New Jersey and
only then I came back to Israel to start
running out so that's that's the journey
that I I took until starting running
high so yeah so and so what was the
world what was the world that you were
living in uh prior to starting run AI
that led to sort of your understanding
of what's happening in the in the
algorithm space in the AI World which
which brought to the which brought life
to to Ranea is a company yeah yeah and
you know as an algorithm engineer and as
I you know in my PhD studies I learned
how to to
dived it into problems right and your
PhD you has to do that right you you're
going you're taking on a problem and you
want to solve it and to solve it it's
supposed to be a difficult problem a
complex problem and and you must dive
into the problem really understand that
well the problem and and and come up
with the solution
and
that solves that problem so in my PhD I
really understood well how to deep dive
into problems and it was amazing it was
something that I took with me afterwards
and and when we started run AI for me it
was really important to find a problem
that that is complex and that we can
solve you know with technology with deep
with deep technology I think before we
started run Ai and both me and umring my
co-founder and we started from a black
page essentially like everything was
possible from from our perspective like
we went we wanted to choose what we were
going to want to we knew we want to
build a startup a company but you know
what we want to do that was open
and
and we looked for a problem to solve
and I think one of the first things that
we noticed and we and we studied is a
the AI space it was in 2017 an AI deep
learning started to emerge back then and
for us we really felt that
AI is is real and it's going to change
the world it's like a big big revolution
it's a new technology we nuke it amazing
capabilities that for sure will change
the world in in so many aspects
in
the first decisions decision that we got
is just to be in that AI space to be
part of that Revolution to help change
the world and with AI and and
we wanted to be there we knew there will
be opportunities that will open for us
and there will be problems to solve so
that was our first decision we want to
be in the AI space and and we want to
look for the problem that we want to
solve so we started like that
I guess and so they're looking at
yeah yeah go ahead
no it did it became more more you know
and more more complex on fighting the
problem man but I'm I I I like to speak
about finding the problem that we want
to solve when you're starting a company
and that's like the most important thing
I think
is is finding a problem that someone
experienced in the day-to-day
and and understanding what the problem
the the different aspects of the problem
how did the Persona experience that
problem in how how what's the different
tools the different solutions that are
out there that can might maybe solve the
problem so understanding every aspect of
the problem and what surrounds the
problem is really really important and
and we did it in in Iran AI it took us a
lot of time
um but but it was beneficial afterwards
and what was the the big overarching
pain point that you saw that that
Engineers have or that algorithm
researchers have when it comes to their
their work that you as an orchestration
platform figured that you could make a
difference there
but listen when we started run AI and
the first idea
was
the we wanted to shrink the time it
takes
to train AI models to run those ai ai
workloads well first idea was was that
if we could
shrink the time it takes for researchers
to train models that it would be amazing
because because
and a model that can be trained in two
weeks could be trained in like two hours
then data scientists and researchers
could maybe
train the same model on more data
and do more computation or or train a
bigger model with more parameters more
complex mode that can solve maybe even a
better a more complex problem
and they could could get more out of it
right so if we could shrink the time it
takes to train models the data
scientists and researchers will find a
way to get it back
to you know to a long time but but they
could train bigger more to solve more
complex problems get better accuracy
better performance so that was the
initial idea
and that we started with we raised money
and we raised from tlv Partners in 2018
we raised three million dollars
um from Rona and Ross again and and we
started there
but
but when we started we saw that
that's not really a problem that
researchers are experiencing their
day-to-day right it's like they have so
many problems other problems much
simpler problems about you know relating
to infrastructure to running the Jupiter
notebooks the things related to data and
so many problems that are not related to
just shrinking the training time
so and and for us that's when we met the
market when we met people that's
something that we realized quite quickly
that that
we need to change we need to change the
problem that we want to solve
and
and we did that in the first year I
think it took us time it took us time to
understand that and we need to change
um but it was one of the things that we
did is is speaking to people a lot
so we walked quite a lot on on getting
meetings
with data scientists with researchers
with with I.T people with developed
people that help researchers so we just
walked a lot on on creating meetings
with a lot of people
just trying to understand the world that
that day to day the problems that they
experience
let's dive if you will into the
researchers as a as a as a sort of a
community and will you know imagine a
traditional researcher wherever in the
world working on any problem whether it
be as a part of a group or or
individually what is their what is their
pain point today in their ability to get
a high-end production grade machine
learning algorithm to the market
and yeah so you know
I think if we look in in perspective of
infrastructure right Computer Resources
so researchers really depend on on the
compute power that they get to train
their models and so on and they can
spend a lot of time on data on
manipulating data on cleaning that and
doing you know most of their time will
go on that just you know problems
relating to that
but when they get to the point where
they start train models then they also
depend on the amount of computing power
that they can get access to
and and then you know what we understood
that researchers don't really want to
deal with infrastructure with computers
just want to run their jobs and that's
it and get you know just train their
models they iterate experiment very fast
and
so it's really collided with us that we
really wanted to do things relating to
infrastructure to compute power right
that's our expertise we wanted to bring
technology to that area
so quickly we realized that the people
that we we find a joint language was the
I.T persons the the
platform Engineers who were building
platforms and infrastructure for their
AI teams
they had problems with infrastructure
they had problems relating to how to
orchestrate a computer to Orchestra gpus
how to allocate gpus how to manage and
make the most out of their
infrastructure and and just sell it to
their researchers and and and and data
scientists
so so with that's one that's the problem
that we solve essentially on how
orchestrating Computer Resources for AI
getting the most out of them getting
tools for platform Engineers to manage
and to allocate those resources very
easily and and efficiently and then and
then you know the end users are the data
scientists the researchers who are
actually running their job training
models maybe deploying models and
consume those Computer Resources
and so if we're looking at what ended up
being most useful for for these
researchers as they as you started
working with them you know letting them
work with your platform what were really
the tools that you discovered were
really the the what the really the
enablers that unblocked them or the the
tools that really provided them the most
value in reaching good high quality
models what what were really the the the
high moments in your platform that gave
them that experience
and
so
I'd say it was Western in in
you know
the tools that we gave them is just
tools that abstract the infrastructure
just letting them get access to
computers as as fast as possible
once they're running the the the models
the training they're training the models
then it's it's a different story it's
this is the
the the tools that they need there is
more like envelopes tools analog tools
relating to experiment management like
tracking and results of experiments and
visualizing the results you know storing
them getting access to those bar matters
so
experiment tracking experiment
management visualization tools a lot of
things that are really important for
data scientists but
um we're not providing such tools just
do it typically we will we're like
integrating with other tools that
provide those tools for those like
envelopes tools that we integrate with
and we'll with coming more from the on
the infrastructure angle and and we'll
help help platform Engineers to
integrate different envelopes Solutions
different envelopes tools like
experiment management and others
um
and and so we help them integrate those
tools very easily and and and then
researchers can use them in a simple way
and then awesome right and I think you
know when it comes and it really depends
also on on which where the organization
at right there that we see we work with
a lot of organizations where we're
working with big banks with um with a
become Automotive companies you know
they're doing a lot of AI and we have
Healthcare customers they're gaming and
gaming they are amazing new stuff going
on right with the hair with generative
Ai and computer vision we have several
customers there you know edu so it
really depends on the type of the
company where they are at this and the
stage of the AI journey and
the simplest you know
there are the advanced users that do
more advanced things uh and and they
need more advanced tools and they are
like simple more simple like citizen
data scientists well um we need simpler
simpler tools
yeah makes sense and so for Speed fast
forwarding uh with the nature of these
20 minute conversations we have to fast
forward unfortunately sometimes when we
get to to today for more than four and a
half years later where where are we at
today with with the Run AI
oh yeah well novels
hi I told you it's a fast forward I
wasn't joking wow we've been so for so
much in this four and a half years wow
so much I think like you know the first
deal for us was about exploring
exploring the initial idea and exploring
the market and and getting and and
really understanding the problem that we
want to solve the problem around
orchestrating a infrastructure and
compute resources so that I think it
took us a year right that's that's a lot
of time it took us a lot of time to to
understand the problem that we want to
solve but once we understood it and we
understood really well and we knew how
we want to solve the problem also
technology wise and product wise and so
on but I think that was the first year
um we pivoted right to to solve that
problem to solve that problem for the
the new persona the infrastructure
platform Engineers not data scientists
those are like the main personas for us
right now m
I think then we had we had a period of
time of of building the product taking
it to the market and what is the
understanding how to how to sell it
right how to go on a meeting with a
customer present a demo as this talk
about the product talk about the
solution
to really touching the problem of the
the users the the prospects Ben
it took time right it took time and and
that's we did that right we had our
first customers really felt the product
Market fit right there the traction from
the market and really felt that people
loved the product when they when when
they start playing with it right and
there was a period of time right we got
to I think to one millionaire uh one
million dollar yeah we scaled beyond
that right that's another period of time
and going for one million to 10 million
dollars they are then you know from 10
million dollars to 100 million dollars
there that's it it already knew story
this but I think every every time period
in our company was totally different the
challenges were different and our
interactions with people were so
different and you know me and only if we
look at if I look on myself whether we
changed along that four years
four and a half years and very very much
and I you know I can speak a lot on
every every period of life that we had
and so that's yeah and nowadays with
nowadays we're scaling now nowadays we
we the the water Market is established
it's all about goals and but more you
know we need to do next we're planning
next year 2023 right now and so we need
a we need to have like amazing
multipliers next year we're talking
about you know some multipliers that
that make you think right okay
it's a challenge right you need to do
much more of what we did until now so we
need to do like like 4X 5x next year
right that's that's crazy like 4x5x for
what we did until now right so that's uh
that's a lot in terms of of building the
pipeline right bringing prospects and
customers and and in terms of converting
that Pipeline with sales people training
those people those people you know that
so
scaling the company so a lot of
challenges relating to that
well yeah really yeah and this was so
such a fun conversation thank you so
much for your time and your uh your
insights I loved going back to the
beginning and understanding how you
figured out the market and the landscape
of these and these researchers and what
they really need to provide the value
the scale of run AI we have so much in
the middle to catch up on so I'm already
inviting you for for some more episodes
to do with me so I I appreciate your
time and your your insights and best of
luck with this upcoming year which
sounds incredible and so uh will be
great thank you very much thank you
thank you so much